NOTHING TO HIDE.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT IT OFF
AIR.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: IN INTERVIEW HE
ADMITS HIS ATTEMPT TO
UNDERMINE AFTER HIS BOSS JIM
COMEY WAS FIRED AND IT WAS,
OF COURSE, DUE TO RUSSIA.
>> I WAS SPEAKING TO THE MAN
WHO HAD JUST RUN FOR THE
PRESIDENCY AND WON THE
ELECTION FOR THE PRESIDENCY
AND WHO MIGHT HAVE DONE SO
WITH THE AID OF THE
GOVERNMENT OF RUSSIA, OUR
MOST FORMIDABLE ADVERSARY ON
THE WORLD STAGE AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT TROUBLED ME
GREATLY.
>> HOW LONG WAS IT AFTER
THAT THAT YOU DECIDED TO
START THE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE AND
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATIONS INVOLVING THE
PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK THE NEXT DAY I
MET WITH THE TEAM
INVESTIGATING THE RUSSIA
CASES AND I ASKED THE TEAM
TO GO BACK AND CONDUCT AN
ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE
WHERE ARE WE WITH THESE
EFFORTS AND WHAT STEPS DO WE
NEED TO TAKE GOING FORWARD?
>> Tucker: ALAN DERSHOWITZ
IS A RETIRED HARVARD LAW
PROFESSOR THE AUTHOR OF THE
BOOK THE CASE AGAINST THE
DEMOCRATIC HOUSE IMPEACHING
TRUMP AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
PROFESSOR, THANKS VERY MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
SO NOW THE SUSPICIONS TO
MANY ARE CONFIRMED BY ONE OF
THE PLAYERS IN IT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DISCUSSED TRYING TO REMOVE
THE PRESIDENT USING THE 25TH
AMENDMENT.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO
THAT?
>> WELL, IF THAT'S TRUE, IT
IS CLEARLY AN ATTEMPT AT
COULDDATA.
LET'S TAKE THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO.
LET'S ASSUME THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES WAS IN
BED WITH THE RUSSIANS,
COMMITTED TREASON AND
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
THE 25TH AMENDMENT SIMPLE
SUPPLY IRRELEVANT TO THAT.
THAT'S WHY HAVE YOU
IMPEACHMENT PROVISION.
THE 25TH AMENDMENT IS ABOUT
WOODROW WILSON HAVING A
STROKE.
IT'S ABOUT A PRESIDENT BEING
SHOT AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
PERFORM HIS OFFICE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENTS
AND IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES.
ANY JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WHO EVEN MENTIONED
THE 25TH AMENDMENT IN THE
CONTEXT OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS COMMITTED A GRIEVOUS
OFFENSE AGAINST THE
CONSTITUTION.
THE FRAMERS OF THE 25TH
AMENDMENT HAD IN MIND
SOMETHING VERY SPECIFIC AND
TRYING TO USE THE 25TH
AMENDMENT TO CIRCUMVENT THE
IMPEACHMENT PROVISIONS OR TO
CIRCUMVENT AN ELECTION IS A
DESPICABLE ACT OF
UNCONSTITUTIONAL POWER
GRABBING.
AND YOU WERE RIGHT WHEN YOU
SAID IT REMINDS ME OF WHAT
HAPPENS IN THIRD WORLD
COUNTRIES.
LOOK, THESE PEOPLE MAY HAVE
BEEN WELL-INTENTIONED.
THEY MAY HAVE BELIEVED THEY
WERE SERVING THE INTEREST OF
THE UNITED STATES, BUT YOU
HAVE TO OBEY THE LAW AND THE
LAW IS THE CONSTITUTION.
AND THE 25TH AMENDMENT IS AS
CLEAR AS COULD BE
INCAPACITY.
UNABLE TO PERFORM OFFICE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED.
THAT'S WHY YOU NEED TWO
THIRDS OF THE HOUSE AND TWO
THIRDS OF THE SENATE
AGREEING AND IT HAS TO BE ON
THE BASIS OF A MEDICAL OR
PSYCHOLOGICAL INCAPACITY.
NOT ON THE BASIS OF EVEN THE
MOST EXTREME CRIMES WHICH
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE WERE
COMMITTED.
BUT EVEN IF THEY WERE, THAT
WOULD NOT BE A BASIS FOR
INVOKING THE 25TH AMENDMENT.
I CHALLENGE ANY LEFT WING
PERSON TO GET ON TELEVISION
AND TO DEFENDER THE USE OF
THE 25TH AMENDMENT.
I CHALLENGE ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE IN THE
GET TRUMP AT ANY COST CAMP
TO COME ON TELEVISION AND
JUSTIFY THE USE OF THE 25TH
AMENDMENT OTHER THAN FOR
PHYSICAL OR PSYCHIATRIC
INCAPACITY.
>> I BET THEY ARE DOING THAT
NOW.